So I showed you how we rewrite the
query likelihood retrieval function
into a form that looks like the formula
of this slide.
After we make the assumption about the
smoothing the language model.
Based on the collection language model.
If you look at the this rewriting it
actually would give us two benefits.
The first benefit is it helps us better
understand this ranking function.
In particular, we're going to show that
from this formula we can see smoothing
with the collection language model will
give us something like a TF IDF
weighting and length normalization.
The second benefit is that it also
allows us to compute the query likelihood
more efficiently.
In particular, we see that the main
part of the formula is a sum over the
matched query terms.
So this is much better than if we take
a sum over all the words.
After we smooth the document language
model, we send you to have non zero
probabilities for all the words.
So this new form of the formula is much
easier to score or to compute.
It's also interesting to note that the
last term here is actually independent
of the document, since our goal is to
rank the documents for the same query,
we can ignore this term for ranking.
Because it's going to be the same for
all the documents.
Ignoring it wouldn't affect the order
of the documents.
Inside the sum,
We also see that each matched query
term would contribute.
weight
And this weight actually is very
interesting.
because it looks like a TF IDF
weighting.
First, we can already see it has a
frequency of the word in the query,
just like in the vector space model.
When we take a dot product we see the
word frequency in the query to show up
in such a sum.
And so naturally, this pot would
correspond to the vector element from
the document vector, and here indeed we
can see it actually encodes a weight
that has similar factor to TF IDF
weighting.
I'll let you examine it.
Can you see it?
Can you see which part is capturing TF?
and which part is capturing IDF
weighting?
So if you want you can pause the video
to think more about it.
So, have you noticed that this p
of seen is related to the term
frequency?
In the sense that if a word occurs very
frequently in the document, then the
estimated probability here would
tend to be larger.
So this means this term is really doing
something like TF weighting.
Have you also notice that?
This term in the denominator.
Is actually achieving the effect of
IDF?
Why?
Because
this is the popularity of the term
in the collection.
But it's in the denominator, so if.
The probability in the collection is
larger,
then the weight is actually smaller, and this
means a popular term.
We actually have a smaller weight and
this is precisely what IDF weighting
is doing.
Only that we now have a different form
of TF and IDF.
Remember, IDF
has a log logarithm of
document frequency.
But here we have something different.
But intuitively it achieves a similar
fact.
Interestingly, we also have something
related to the length normalization.
Again, can you see which factor is
related to the document length?
In this formula.
I just say that this term is related to
IDF weighting.
This.
This collection probability, but it
turns out that this term here is
actually related to the document length.
Normalization in particular alpha sub d
might be related to document.
length, so it encodes how much
probability mass we want to give to
unseen words.
How much smoothing do we want to do
?
Intuitively, if a document is long then
we need to do less smoothing because we
can assume that data is large enough.
We probably have observed all the words
that the author could have written, but
the document is short.
Then alpha sub d could be expected to be
to be large.
We need to do more smoothing.
It's like that there are words that
have not been written yet by the other.
So this term appears to penalize long
documenting in that the alpha sub d
would tend to be longer than larger
than.
for a long document.
But note that the alpha sub d also
occurs here.
And so this may not actually be
necessary.
Penalizing long documents effect is not
so clear here.
But as we will see later when we
consider some specific smoothing
methods, it turns out that they do
penalize long documents just like in TF
IDF weighting
and document length
normalization formulas in the vector
space model.
So that's a very interesting
observation, because it means we don't
even have to think about the specific
way of doing smoothing.
We just need to assume that if we
smooth with this collection language
model, then we would have a formula.
That looks like a TF IDF weighting and
documents length normalization.
What's also interesting is that we have
very fixed form of the ranking
function.
And see we have not heuristically put a
logarithm here.
In fact, you can think about why we
will have a logarithm here.
If you look at the assumptions that we
have made, it will be clear it's
because we have.
used logarithm of query likelihood
for scoring.
And we turned the product into a sum of
logarithm of probability and that's why
we have this logarithm.
Note that if we only want to
heuristically implement the TF weight
and IDF weighting, we don't
necessarily have to have a logarithm
here.
Imagine if we drop this logarithm, we
would still have TF and IDF weighting.
But what's nice with probabilistic
modeling is that we are automatically
given a logarithm function here.
And that's basically a fixed form of
the formula that we did not really have
to heuristically design, and in this
case, if you try to drop this
logarithm, the more of probably one work
as well as if you keep logarithm.
So a nice property of probabilistic
modeling is that by following some
assumptions and probability rules we will
get a formula automatically.
And the formula would have a particular
form, like in this case.
And if we heuristically design the
formula, we may not necessary end up
having such a specific form.
So to summarize, we talked about the
need for smoothing document language
model, otherwise would give zero
probability for unseen words in the
document.
And that's not good for scoring a query
with such an unseen world.
And it's also necessary in general to
improve the accuracy of estimating the
model represents the topic of this
document.
The general idea of smoothing in
retrieval is to use the collection
language Model to
Give us some clue about the which unseen
word should have a higher
probability.
That is, the probability of an unseen
word is assumed to be proportional to
its probability in the collection.
With this assumption, we've shown that
we can derive a general ranking formula
for query likelihood that has the effect
of TF IDF weighting and document length
normalization.
We also see that through some
rewriting, the scoring of such a
ranking function is primarily based on
sum of weights on match query terms,
just like it in the vector space model.
But the actual ranking function is
given us automatically by the
probability rules and the assumptions that
we have made and unlike in the vector
space model where we have to
heuristically.
Think about the form of the function.
However, we still need to address the
question how exactly we should smooth
the document language model.
How exactly we should use the reference
language model based on the collection
to adjust the probability of the
maximum likelihood estimate?
And this is the topic of the next
lecture.